[Musique]
ma mère mondiale
l'ennemi peut être utile utile à la
france notre pays
dutil à l'europe mais aussi utile à la
planète parce que nous savons que nous
n'avons pas seulement dès que nous en
sommes en quelque sorte solidaires nous
en sommes coresponsables volant que nous
vivons à peu près tranquillement sous
ses bonnes étoiles
ici en europe il vous faut savoir que de
l'autre côté du monde finalement presque
à notre porte
il y à 1 milliard 400 millions d'hommes
de femmes et d'enfants qui n'ont pas
accès à l'eau potable que 40% du
continent africain vit avec moins d'un
dollar par jour
la série aucune originalité justement
des verts depuis un bail justement quel
est le cas durant ces 35 dernières
années
autant d'espèces ont disparu pendant
cinq milles on voit si nous n'agissons
pas face à cette urgence écologique et
bien ne laisserons à nos enfants une
planète invivable d'une planète
désertifier dans laquelle ils n'auront
aucun avenir
cependant c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous les verts ne nous investissons
beaucoup dans la campagne
nous croyons que nous pouvons apporter
une amélioration à la qualité de votre
vie
la qualité de ce qui arrive dans votre
assiette de votre alimentation
la qualité de l'air que vous respirez
vous avez beaucoup entendu parler des
ogm et vous êtes une très grande
majorité à dire non aujourd'hui ce que
certaines grandes sociétés
internationales veulent nous imposer
alors que on ne nous a jamais demandé
notre avis vous êtes contre cette
uniformisation de ce que nous mangeons
ce que certains appellent la malbouffe
mais vous savez aussi que vos enfants
sont atteints d'allergies de maladies
respiratoires dans la plupart des
grandes villes de france l'asthme par
exemple augmenté de 10 à 15% alors oui
c'est vrai on ne peut pas continuer
comme ça
et nous savons que si nous continuons à
gaspiller
si nous continuons à utiliser trop les
automobiles à transporter trop de
marchandises avec des camions comme le
dit le livre blanc de l'union européenne
à terme l'europe sera à seatlle et ce
n'est pas ce que nous voulons et c'est
parce que nous l'avons dit pendant des
années sans être édité par nos
partenaires politiques d'aujourd'hui
et bien c'est parce que il y a eu le
silence et le mépris de laon n'a trouvé
que l'on est arrivé elle était ce prof
comme la vache folle le poulet à la
dioxine mais aussi le brevetage du
vivant les ogm et redescendre
catastrophe d'azf
c'est la raison pour laquelle voter
utile le 21 alliés c'est donner plus de
poids au vert dès ses premiers tours
afin qu'ils pèsent sur la partenaire
deuxième qui moquent ils contribuent à
transformer la société qui contribuent à
faire de la gauche une gauche du
développement durable et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous invite dès le 21
avril au matin à voter utile
c'est-à-dire à revel
[Musique]